LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
For showing up.
We appreciate it.
And we have a lot to
talk about, clearly.
There's two quick
remembrances that we'd
like to do before we get
started that we thought
would be an important way to
frame our conversation today.
The first remembrance is
a land acknowledgment,
a practice of beginning public
gatherings by acknowledging
and honoring the native
land on which we sit,
one that some folks have been
doing for a very long time.
For others of us,
it's a newer practice.
But one connected
to this conversation
about understanding and
undoing racism and oppression,
which as I'm sure we'll talk
about, part of that work
is changing our sense of
how we tell our story of who
and where we are.
So this land acknowledgment
is one we use at Emerson.
It says, we are on the
ancestral and unseated lands
of the Massachusett people
whose name was appropriated
by this commonwealth.
We pay respect to the
Massachusett elders
past and present.
We acknowledge the
truth of violence
perpetrated in the
name of this country
and make a commitment to
uncovering that truth.
The second remembrance
we want to offer
is for John O'Neal, who we lost
just last month on February
14th.
John was a co-founder in 1963
of the Free Southern Theater,
which was a cultural arm of the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee, or SNCC, during
the Civil Rights Movement.
In the 1980s, he changed
the Free Southern Theater
into Junebug Productions,
a company that
still lives and works very hard
in New Orleans around issues
of oppression and injustice.
Without him, we
would not be here.
This conversation
So we want to honor him.
Keith, tell us more
about this play.
I haven't seen it.
I've read it.
It's an extraordinary story.
Tell us a little bit
more about where it goes
and what it's urging
us to grapple with.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: It's
about to be seven years old.
And it will be when we bring
it to New York this fall.
And American Moor tells the
story, in simplest terms,
of a large, powerful,
middle-middle-aged
African-American male who
finds himself auditioning
for the role of Shakespeare's
iconic black eponymous
hero, Othello, with all
of the ups and downs
that that introduces
to any conversation.
And as is most
often the case, he
finds himself auditioning
opposite a much
younger white director
who proceeds to tell him
who and how Othello should be.
And so in the 10
minutes of the audition,
he has an hour and a
half inner monologue
that the audience is privy to.
And that is the
crux of the play.
And of course, that
allows us a platform
to discuss issues of race
and implicit racial bias,
issues of empathy, whose
perspectives are important,
who gets to make art.
Issues of love.
What does it look like?
How is it manifested between us?
Issues of the American theater.
What theater are we making?
Why are we making it?
How are we making it?
For what reasons
is it being made?
Even when we are reaching out
in supposedly directions meant
to support and uplift
us as a culture,
is that happening for
the proper reasons?
Are we doing the introspection?
And if we are, are our support
mechanisms strong enough
to support us in the muddy,
icky, difficult work of getting
at the truth in plays
about these issues?
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
I have to say that,
just in reading it,
I was reminded of Du
Bois's 1903 statement
about double consciousness
and this experience of twoness
that black folks and other
folks, hyphenated Americans,
have of having both always
the experience of ourself
and the experience of
how we're being viewed.
This peculiar
experience, he calls it.
And another thing so
wonderful about the play
is how it takes a very personal
experience of the audition room
and uses that as a window
into all of the complexities,
just as you said.
David, I wonder what
you want to add,
what the view is from
there as far as being--
not in the audition room but
being an institutional leader.
DAVID HOWSE: So
I'll start by saying
that I was never going to be
that one who talked about race.
I spent a lot of time not
trying to have the conversation.
But as they say, the things
that you try to stay away from
are often the things
that you're called to.
And so here I am,
having this conversation
with you and with you.
And it's a pleasure to
be in the conversation.
I'd like to say that
I've been exempt
from racial oppression or
aggressions or inequities.
But that would not be the case.
In fact, both as a
performer and as an arts
administrator, as a leader of
various cultural organizations,
I've experienced its
burden on many occasions.
And, much like this inner
voice, this character
that we hear throughout the play
who has some anger, some rage,
I have to say that there exists
anger within me at times.
It was James Baldwin who
said, and I paraphrase,
but if you're a Negro
and consciously living
in this world, you live with
a constant state of rage.
And I jokingly tell people
that my rage sits right here.
And it's not the fact that
we have anger or rage.
It's what I choose
to do with that rage.
We can actually
engage it consciously,
or we can surrender to it.
And I choose to
engage it consciously.
So we are experiencing
a time where
we are no different from past
history but in a new moment
where we're experiencing these
aggressions in different ways.
And I'll say, one of
the experiences that I
had when I joined the
theater world originally,
from the music world,
and I was invited
to my first meeting of theater
directors here in the region.
And so I readied myself, and
I went over to the meeting.
And just to set the context,
I walk into the room,
and the room- the
tables are white.
The chairs are white.
The walls are white.
You know where this is going.
And everybody at
the table was white.
And so, of course, I take my
rightful place at the table.
And a very kind and
well-meaning, I believe,
woman, white woman, leaned
over to me and said kindly,
this is the director's meeting.
To which I was consciously
engaging my rage
and said to her, I know.
It's shocking, isn't it?
And I left it at that.
So these are one of the many
experiences that we have
that we have to
understand personally.
I have to understand how to
deal with it, how to manage it,
and to hold onto my dignity
in those situations.
And so I appreciate
and certainly can
connect with this
particular character
in Keith's role in the play, of
someone who harbors feelings.
Not always, but on
regular occasion,
and how to manage
that and engage it
in a way that
honors my experience
and then connects
me to other people.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
I really appreciate that
language around rage.
And it's good to know that
your rage that's right there.
DAVID HOWSE: It's right here.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Noted.
And to not deny that it's
there but to recognize
that we have a choice about how
we engage and respond to it.
And so for all of
us up here, we've
made a choice to do
that with theater,
with the performing arts.
And so I think we had discussed
the importance of beginning
by talking about, well,
why is that the choice?
Of all the tools that
we have as individuals,
as a city, as a society,
to grapple with this stuff,
why theater?
Part of the origin story of
the Free Southern Theater
is John O'Neal and other
artists who made the choice
to join SNCC and
go south in the 60s
were grappling with these
two identities, their artist
self and their activist self,
and how to reconcile that.
And John said, well, if theater
means anything anywhere,
it ought to mean something here.
And then they went about the
work of figuring that out.
So continuing that question,
what does it mean here and now?
Why is it the tool?
How and why is theater useful?
DAVID HOWSE: I'll just
say for me, it's theater.
But arts in general,
I think, are a vehicle
that allows us to have
a shared experience,
to let down our guards
just for a minute
and walk in someone
else's shoes,
to actually see each other and
see our common humanity if we
choose to, in a
way that we don't
have in our daily experiences.
We live in isolated communities,
in isolated experiences.
And I think the arts has a way
for us to see and experience
things in a new way.
And again, more importantly,
to let down our guard
and take that moment
to open up our hearts
and open up our minds
to experience something
in ways that we don't have those
experiences on a daily walk.
And so for me, it's
been a real tool.
And again, there's
an argument on art
for art's sake and art as a
vehicle for something else.
Yes, and, right?
If art for art's sake
matters, I believe in that.
But I also think if
it has an opportunity
to connect us more
deeply to who we
are as individuals
and as a community,
then why would we miss
out on that opportunity?
So a lot of the work
that we do at ArtsEmerson
really comes out of that spirit.
We made a commitment
several years ago
to be a part of
a citywide effort
around civic transformation
through race.
And so a lot of the
work that we present
comes out of that commitment.
But that's just to say that
there are many conversation
that we have through the
theater and many issues
that we try to tackle.
But knowing that we
live here in Boston,
and we live in a society
where the fabric,
the American fabric, the fabric
that keeps Boston together,
is constantly being eroded
by this racial tension.
We've chosen to engage it.
But the common thread, I
think, through our work
is this one of common humanity.
And I often quote the
poets because I love them,
but Maya Angelou-- it's as if
she were speaking for me when
she says, in all of my work
and everything that I do,
I choose to believe
that we as humans are
more alike than we are unalike.
And then to use that statement
to tear down the walls
that we build between us
because we are different.
And so we are choosing
to use a theater platform
as a prompt to conversations
that actually allow
us to connect more deeply
to one another in an effort
to create a more thriving,
more vibrant, more
equitable, and more just,
and more compassionate--
I could go on.
A more compassionate
community for everybody,
not just for those
who are typically
ones to be patrons of the
arts but for everyone.
And so I could go
on about that role,
but I think it's a critical tool
that we have at our disposal
in our communities
that we often leave off
the table when we're thinking
about civic challenges.
And so we are here to
say, let's make arts
a part of that conversation.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Great.
Thank you.
Keith, how about you?
Why theater?
What's useful about having this
conversation in the theater?
KEITH HAMILTON
COBB: What he said.
The difference
between us, David,
is that I wasn't called
to do anything else,
to express my humanity
any other way.
When you were
being introduced, I
was sitting here
listening to all
of the ways in which you
could have applied yourself
and still can.
All that I do is towards
artistic expression
of some form.
I make furniture.
Now there might be some way that
I can make furniture and lend
it to this discussion
or it can reflect
this discussion in some way.
But theater seemed to be the
most ready form of expression.
And if we're talking
about the actor using
what his experience
is, her experiences,
to embody other characters,
I can only start with myself.
And myself is this experience
here in this culture.
So that flavors everything.
And depending on how aware
the ensemble and the director
and the production
team is to that,
then our social activism
becomes evident in whatever play
we pick up to do on some level.
DAVID HOWSE: In many
ways, you're very humble.
But in my experience,
and it's been
said that artists are the
gatekeepers of truth, right?
Civilization's radical voice.
And so artists actually
speak truth to us
and can see the world--
very special people with
sensitivities that some of us
don't have.
But then to reflect
who we are back to us
and allow us to engage
it, not because you're
trying to do social work,
but you're literally just
trying to show us who we are.
And it's our choice
to engage that.
I think being close to art--
if you're not close to artists,
you need to get
close to artists,
because they will
tell you the truth.
And if you listen deeply
enough, you will see yourself
and you'll see each other.
So I feel that artists
have a special role
and have for decades
and years, years.
A role in society that
allows us to enter
a space that wouldn't exist
without those storytellers.
So that's who you are.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
Across cultures, as well.
What has your experience
been doing this play?
Speaking these kinds
of truths, looking
for these kinds of truths.
The impact it's had,
conversations it started.
How has it been touring
this conversation?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: This
is a very particular play.
Listen, y'all.
This is an extraordinary play.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
Extraordinary.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Yeah.
And I need you to
know right here
that I don't say that
about anything else
in my entire body of work.
And I will not until something
beyond this play comes along.
But it is unique
in several ways.
It is unique in the nature
of the stage picture.
It is unique in its
voice and the story
it tells, the experience that
it tries to impart to you.
And it does it in some
ways that I can't even
sit here and say,
hey, I'm a genius.
I did all that.
I was sort of a conduit.
It happened.
And immediately, people
began talking back
to it who were not
African-American male actors,
who I thought were the only
people going to like this play.
They were from all other walks
of life and age spectrums
and sexual spectrums
and racial identities.
And talking about how
they saw themselves.
So this gets back to
what you were saying, is
they were all looking at
me doing me and saying,
that truth is true to all of us.
And that has been
the salient energy.
It affects people
very viscerally.
And they need to speak back,
and they need to speak up to it.
So it generates discussion.
It also answers questions
that don't get asked.
I think we are
perpetually, at least
now at this point in
time, we're reaching
some sort of odd
critical mass of energy
on the race issue
in this country
and what it's going to do.
Like global warming, like any
other crisis that's pending.
It's something that we're
all feeling on some level
and trying to talk about it.
But it's very, very difficult
for a myriad of reasons.
One of the biggest to me,
one of the most salient,
is that the heinousness of the
crime upon which all of this is
established and built
cannot be discussed.
It almost has to
remain nameless because
of the size and nature of it.
When we think that all
of this is predicated
upon the ownership of
black bodies, every dime
that every one of us has in our
pocket somehow comes from that,
then it is impossible
to own that.
It is impossible.
It is far beyond inconvenient.
It is just not a
discussion that we
have the time to have
when life is tough enough.
And we have to get
through our days,
and we have to get
to the next place.
And there's all
sorts of other crises
that we have to deal with.
I don't know.
I lost my train of thought.
I get started with that--
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
When you go to the trauma
that all of this is built on,
I wasn't sure if
you were talking
about this, the United States
of America, or the Americas.
Or if you're talking about
the American theater,
or if you were talking
about black performance
in particular.
I wonder if either one of you
want to take us there and talk
about that twoness
of being an artist,
a truth teller but also being a
black artist and truth teller.
Wrestling and reckoning with
the origin of black performance,
which is slave ships, auction
blocks, minstrel shows,
all of that.
Yeah?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Yeah.
Just to put a cap on
that last thought,
audiences come to this play
unable to ask the questions,
because the questions
are so big and so dark
and mean taking on
such responsibility
if the answers are
not convenient.
And so the play says, just
sit and watch and listen.
And it answers a lot of the
questions that don't get asked.
I find that audiences, having
this communal experience
in that forum, feel almost like
they've been given the gift
to feel and understand
things that is not
convenient to live on any level
outside of the theater space.
So that's where I
was going with that.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah Did
you want to respond to that?
DAVID HOWSE: Yeah.
I'll speak from my
role as a presenter
and as an African-American
man in the presenting world.
I live in conflict most of the
time, this dual consciousness.
And when you talk
about the stories
that we get to tell in
the American theater, who
gets to tell them and what
gets told, I'm in conflict.
And I'm of two minds.
On one hand, a
lot of the stories
that we tell about
the other experience,
whether that's a black
experience or any person
of color experience,
is one that's
steeped in suffering and trauma.
And there's an important
aspect of making visible
that suffering and that trauma.
Because in telling
those stories,
we are confirming that
we are indeed humans.
So that's on one hand.
But on the other hand, we are
not defined by that suffering
and by that trauma.
And people of color, and
black people and others,
are bigger than the suffering
that has defined them
and the suffering that
they've endured over time.
And so I find
myself in conflict,
wanting to be able to tell
the stories that say, see?
This is a hard experience.
But also saying, but I am
so much bigger than that.
We have resilient stories and
stories of triumph and stories
of celebration.
Unfortunately, people
are not as comfortable
with those stories of triumph
and joy and celebration.
There's a deep
comfort that makes me
uncomfortable in the suffering.
I call it black suffering.
Other people call
it black suffering.
Of delivering that
pain and drama.
There's a comfort and there's
an expectation around it.
And in many ways,
by only offering
one story of an experience,
we are in many ways
confirming the very things that
we are trying to break apart.
And so when I'm actually looking
for work with my colleagues
at ArtsEmerson, we're
looking for both stories.
And I have to say that it's
harder to find those stories.
And when we find those
stories that are just
talking about celebration
and success, people say,
there's no story there.
There's no drama.
Where's the conflict?
Because we're looking for
those confirming statements,
those prejudices and
deeply ingrained social
understandings of what
others' experiences are.
So I sit in conflict with
this dual consciousness
and work actively to
support and promote work
that is telling both stories.
And again, I'm not
saying in any way
that we're trying to hide
a part of the experience,
because that is true and it's
lived and it needs to be told.
But it's just not
the only story.
And I'd be interested,
Keith, because
in the American theater,
traditionally audiences
have been predominately white.
And that still is the case
in many, many theaters
around the country.
And the conflict
lies in that we have
to make sure that the
masses, the people who
are supporting
those theaters, are
comfortable in
these conversations.
So how we then navigate
those two stories
and bring an audience along
is a constant struggle
and a constant opportunity
at the same time.
So for me, I look at
these two opportunities.
And I imagine, as a creative,
as a black creative,
I want both stories to be told.
I don't want to be
defined by that suffering.
And if I want to just
write a play about love,
it just is about love.
It doesn't have to be about
black love or black suffering.
Love is just love, right?
But sometimes we're not
able to tell that story
without the other lens on it.
And so this is the thing that
I struggle with as I actually
look to bring work
to a community that
is trusting us to actually
tell the full story
of the experience.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
I'm reminded, Keith,
of one of the--
I think it's from the opening
stage directions or opening
note in your script,
which you all
won't get to read or
experience when you see it.
But you actually
have a note in there
to another actor who may do
it, or another director that
may work on it, about how
to approach the audience,
and exactly what you're saying.
This relationship of, it's
going to be tough, y'all.
And I approach it
with love and comfort.
What is the
relationship to comfort?
It's, we're going to
struggle, but my heart
is open to you and for you.
How do you navigate all of that
in the 90 minutes of the show?
We're hearing a bit
about David's experience
of that relationship between
comfort and challenge,
how you stay in relationship
through struggle, basically.
How do you do that as a
performer in this show?
How do you think about that?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
Just in this show,
just in terms of pure
mechanics of the piece,
there is a prologue of
which you saw 3/4 just now.
And there's another
couple of pages.
And at that point, the director
calls him in to this audition.
And the audience then follows
him into this audition
and goes on this
journey with him.
And in that prologue,
he has done this work.
And if it were
another sort of space,
I would be up
close to you, and I
would be speaking more
conversationally with you.
And they understand after that
eight pages has transpired
that he's not typical in what--
if there's such thing as an
average American white person,
and you said to them average
African-American urban male,
they would have an image.
And this fella, because
of how he speaks, because
of how he's dressed, because
of what he says does,
is atypical to that.
And so there's this sense of
cracking open or catching them
off guard and then
talking in terms that,
again, are very embracing.
Come with me.
Let's explore this together.
And they do.
And again, I don't quite
know how we facilitated that.
But it just tends to work.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
DAVID HOWSE: I think there's a
role for the theater, actually,
to actually make space
and prepare that space so
that conversation between
the actor and the audience
is an authentic one.
Oftentimes, we don't know
how to receive the work.
And so I think it's up to
the theater to actually bring
their audience on
a journey to say,
here's what we're experiencing.
And here's why we think it's
important for us to know it.
And I I'm not sure that
audiences are always prepared.
They see the headline.
They see a trailer.
And they run in.
But the journey
hasn't been happening
for that audience as a community
to actually be able to embrace.
And we then leave
that experience
in all kinds of ways.
And I think this is where
I feel like it's part
of our responsibility
as theater makers,
as presenters, to make sure
that we're in conversation
and dialogue with the
artists and with the audience
around what we are trying
to do collectively.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
Can you say more about
how ArtsEmerson
thinks about that?
Preparing an audience,
getting ready for
and continuing a conversation,
maybe with each show
or across a season, even?
What is it to really think
of the audience as somebody
in the conversation?
DAVID HOWSE: Yeah.
So I don't know that
we're unique in this,
but I think we
think of ourselves--
we talk about
curatorial listening.
So we talk deeply
with the audiences
here and understand, what are
the things that are relevant
and mattering to
you in your life?
And what we try to do
is then reflect that
on what we put on the stage.
And we often go back and say,
have we gotten that right?
But we talk a lot
about the values
that we live in at ArtsEmerson.
And we want everything that you
see to reflect those values.
And so for those
audience members
who are with us in
multiple shows, again,
you can come to one show
and have a great experience.
And we celebrate that.
But for those people
who are actually
tracking what we are trying
to accomplish with our mission
around fostering this calm and
connectivity around difference,
I think it's a different
responsibility.
So we do have
moments where we're
bringing the artist into
the community to actually
talk to the audience, to extend
a genuine invitation to people.
But we're also then giving
the audience an opportunity
to be with that
artist to talk about,
what are you trying to create?
And we do these through
engagement tools that
are outside of the theater.
A play reading book
club, where people
who have no experience,
perhaps, with the theater
are invited to read the
play, to study the play,
to work with a teaching
artist, to actually
engage with the artist, to
perform and see the play.
By the time they get
into that theater,
they more about
the show than I do,
because they've spent
time in community
with people who have different
perspectives from them.
So it's not like
we're all the same.
I'm seeing this play
differently from you.
And we're actually engaging
and creating dialogue.
And so when I say that we think
about the art as a prompt,
we're literally using it
as just the first step.
And what happens for us
is, the conversation that
stems from that, is
really the point for us.
And again, those who are
tracking what we're doing
are seeing the energy and
want to be a part of something
that they're not seeing in
their own individual lives.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
It's a daunting task.
What I think I
hear you describing
is that level of engagement
and community interaction
is really a reinvention
of the theater experience
in a particular community.
And because we can't
do that in the nation,
there's all this
other stuff out there
called theater that
is what theater
has become for Americans
that doesn't do that.
It does not hold the same
place as a cultural nurturer.
Other places, it is in
certain communities.
And so you have a
Herculean thing.
DAVID HOWSE: Well, it's the
work that we've been called to.
And again, it's not
saying that every theater
needs to do it like we do it.
We often ask the question,
what's to be done
and what's ours to do?
And ArtsEmerson was founded at
a time where this city was going
through a transformation, where
there was more people of color
than white people.
And in 2010 when
we were founded,
there are tons of theaters
doing amazing work.
We had to try to figure
out what was uniquely
ours to do in this
city, in this moment
and how could we be a part of
rewriting the city's narrative.
And so we've taken
it upon ourselves
to develop and promote
and support artists
who are telling the stories
that support the work that we're
trying to do here in the city.
So again, it's not
for everyone to do.
And it's not that
we're any better.
We have just a different
focus and a different vision
for what theater can become.
We don't sit in judgment of
our colleagues or anyone else.
But this is the work
that we've chosen to do.
And we've been privileged
with amazing venues,
with amazing
artists, with a very
loyal and committed and
curious, more than anything,
audience who
understands what they
don't know and want to learn
about others' perspectives.
So again, it's Herculean.
And it's just one part.
I'm not saying that arts
is going to cure it all.
We are part of a movement.
And we believe that
arts has a role, just
like all the other interventions
in society's issues.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
I understand that,
and I admire it.
And I think you're right.
I just wish-- for one who
feels that theater is almost
a cure-all, if it were
something that we could all
come to and engage in.
And this sort of
homogenization and co-optation
of American theater
as a business,
as purely a business
concern, means
that you give audiences
what they're going to like.
And that is insidious.
That gets into things--
when I was doing a
production of Lynn Nottage's
Ruined in Denver--
and I had seen it off-Broadway.
And she won the Pulitzer.
And I thought, it's a good play.
I enjoyed the production.
But I got in it, and
I was playing the head
of the government forces.
This English-educated
Congolese man
representing the wealthy class.
And he's just this
sadistic monster.
And I would go home and
look at YouTube testimonials
from women involved in the
mineral conflicts in Congo who
would look at camera,
and all the pain they'd
experienced, that there was
no room for crying anymore.
There's no room.
It was all very deadpan.
And they would relate
these experiences
of these various
factions of soldiers
coming through their village.
And the heinous ways in
which babies were killed
and children were
raped and bayonets--
and I would go back
to rehearsal and I'd
say, how can we present
that to the audience?
How do we show that that
is what our iPhones cause
and our iPads?
and Because those
are the minerals
that go into these devices that
they are being killed over.
And they didn't really have
an answer, other than to say,
well, you know, it's a musical.
And I said, yeah, I know.
I know she wrote a musical.
But it's about this thing.
And it's real.
And how do we create the danger?
If they're all coming to commune
with us and make theater,
and we're making it together,
it's not just us up here
and you out there, and we're
presenting something to you.
But we're involved
in this experience,
another oral
storytelling tradition.
How do we create the
energy that makes us all
leave thinking
something has to change?
Or are we just entertained
because it's happy
and it has a happy ending?
And I worry about
that because of what
we tend to do with just about
everything in our culture.
Anything that we can co-opt
and turn into money, we do.
DAVID HOWSE: And both
things can be true, right?
We do need entertainment.
We need places to
go and release.
But we have to have a balance.
And I think what
I hear you saying
is hungry for more of the
counterbalance of just
pure entertainment.
Things that are safe
and are going to make us
feel comfortable and reconfirm
everything we want to believe.
Where is the space for real,
honest dialogue around things
that don't make us feel good?
And I think that's
where we are now.
We're in a moment-- and just
indulge me for a second--
where there's a lot of talk
in the American theater,
in arts in general, around
the role that race plays.
Diversity, equity, inclusion.
Everyone has an
initiative right now.
And my fear is that the
talk around these issues
is a cover for the things that
can perpetuate and reproduce
the same conditions in some way.
And so I'm very
eager, as are you,
to move beyond the talk of
that safe space of saying,
we're talking about diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
Let's pat ourselves on the back.
Aren't we great?
Because we are denying the
history that we live on.
And until we actually
begin to dismantle
within our institutions,
within the American theater,
within our
organization, dismantle
those systems of
oppression, we are very much
perpetuating the status quo.
And I think there's
a moment where
we have to be truthful
about what we're doing.
Are we doing good?
Are we doing damage
by presenting
these stories and these
spaces that are not
taking care of the stories and
taking care of the artists who
are telling those stories?
So I'm eager for people
to understand the weight
of the good intentions.
Because a number
of theaters-- we've
come a long way in
the American theater.
Just in the New York
Times today, there
was an article about the
new four artistic directors
of color leading
major institutions.
That's significant.
There are more
playwrights of color
being presented and
produced than I've
seen in a very long time.
Not that they
didn't exist before.
But we're just now recognizing
and dignifying them
with the work.
So we've made
incredible progress.
But I feel like we've
still got a ton of work
to do when it comes to
the American theater.
So when we look at
institutions, we're
presenting work
that reflects what
we think the world wants to
see around race and diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
But when you peel
back the layers,
we haven't done our
own internal work.
And I wonder, what is the
accountability mechanism that
makes sure that when we
present works that tackle
ugly issues around race
and gender and classism,
what is the responsibility
of the institution
to prepare itself and
have authentic space
be able to deliver
these stories?
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
Well, I would
love to hear more
about what that work is
that you're calling for
and that you maybe you
feel is necessary to reconcile
the tensions that you're
talking about between the market
and the truth telling task.
That article in
the New York Times
today was really
interesting, because it
was celebrating all these new
faces in leadership positions.
And at the same time,
a couple of those folks
were saying, you know, slow
your roll a little bit.
We still have a long way to go
Thank you for celebrating me.
And we have a long way to go.
So what is the work that
you both feel is necessary?
From the institutional
level, perhaps?
In the creative spaces?
Whatever your perspective is.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Well, I
can't dictate for anybody else.
I read the article, too.
And I'm eager to
see what they do.
But what will be truly
significant is what they do.
And I'm a bit
jaded, because I've
come from seven years of
trying to sell against--
I'm sorry, y'all, this
extraordinary play.
And you'll all come.
You'll all come in April,
and you'll agree with me.
You'll say, he wasn't
just blowing his own horn.
Because it is that thing.
And putting it on
people's desks,
and nobody's talking
to me about this thing,
and pushing and
pushing and pushing.
Because I'm nobody.
If it was Denzel's play,
they'd be doing it.
So you bring these people
into these positions,
and that's great.
But that insidiousness
of the capitalist machine
that I was talking about
begins to overwhelm.
And you find that these new
brown artistic directors
are doing more of what
American theater has become,
which is putting butts
in seats and making money
with celebrity, with stuff
that's easy, with stuff that
doesn't take too long to make.
All the stuff that makes
theater kind of homogeneous.
And we go.
And critics are often
complicit in this.
The criticism in the
American theater,
I've found, judging from when
I was a student at NYU and now,
has become much more of a
support for the theater.
They'll say, well, wasn't that
wonderful what our theater did?
It may not have been Death of
a Salesman, but it was great.
It was great.
That was a great thing.
As opposed to really
taking it apart.
So I could tell you
what the work would
be for me, were I the
artistic director,
were I given that position.
But it's completely unpractical,
what I'd like to do.
The money I would like
to spend, the time I
would like to take with
actors to rehearse a play.
We were talking just earlier
about the intimacy direction
and the whole idea of--
she was talking about
working with her students
about issues of intimacy in
plays, particularly now, when
the sensitivity towards that
in so many ways has been upped.
And how do you work with actors?
And how do you counsel them
to work with each other
in ways that will present to an
audience intimacy that is real,
that they recognize as real?
Closed door, behind
whatever form that takes.
It's a very hard thing to do.
But it's important to--
again, I take Othello
as an example.
If we're going to tell
this story realistically,
if we're going to
tell a new story,
get to the end of it
and feel like something
has been revealed to us,
as opposed to the
same cookie-cutter
play we've seen 15 times
throughout our lives,
then we're going
to have to explore
those moment-to-moment
realities with great depth.
And it's going to be
uncomfortable and hard.
And who's ready for that?
Who has who has that ability?
Who has that time?
And do we care?
Is it important enough to us?
If I keep telling you that
the culture will change
if we embrace theater
in a meaningful way
and give it money and
give it give it support,
will you believe me?
Will you go along
on that experiment?
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
I feel like part of what we're
longing for is a performance
tradition that in
its fullest, as far
as serving a role
in society, where
it is both the irritant that
gets you to look and listen
when you would rather not, and
the bomb that can soothe us--
quite honestly, I'm thinking
right now about the only two
videos I've watched
from New Zealand, which
have been the performances.
One by students, one by bikers,
of a traditional Maori dance
and song of mourning.
And the power of
that performance--
I think about the songs of
the Civil Rights movement.
Those songs, one of
the most impactful,
organizing tactics
used in the movement,
I would argue, that
is simultaneously
healing and pushing.
See us.
And it is healing as we do it.
And see us.
It is both.
It's healing and pushing.
So how can we have a
craft and a business?
I don't know.
That's the question.
Can it be a business if
it maintains that role?
That feels like a
big question for me
and core to what
you're talking about.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
Yeah, absolutely.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: We're going
to open it up for questions.
This is a warning that I'm
going to ask one more question
before turning it to you all.
You ready for that?
No, they're not.
OK.
That was a real warm
up to get you ready.
I want to honor your call to
remind us to keep an eye on joy
and make sure that we end
this part just by asking you
each where and how
this work feeds you.
Because part of
the risk, I think,
is that it is depleting to
us and that we're always
focused on the rage and the
way that that can tire us out.
How does it feed you?
How does it lift you up?
Either generally, or if
there's a particular instance
you can think of.
Because why do it if
it doesn't feed you?
Where and how are you fed?
DAVID HOWSE: Shall I start?
Or should you go?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
Sure, go ahead.
DAVID HOWSE: Anything worth
anything is hard work.
And for me, there's
incredible joy
in what we're trying to create.
And personally, I believe in
things I've not seen before.
And I really believe
that the arts has a role
to play in creating a world and
society and communities where
people are less burdened by our
history of racial injustice.
And so that aspiration, that
deep yearning and urgency
for me, is what makes me spring
out of bed every morning.
The rage is there.
Many of us live with it.
How do we choose to engage it?
I find incredible hope in the
stories that we see today.
I feel like there's
a huge opportunity.
I feel like the world,
particularly the United States,
is listening in a new way.
And it is our opportunity
to be truthful around what
we're hearing and
how we're actually
moving those stories forward.
So to be a part of a craft, to
be a part of an industry that
is privileged to lift up, to
make visible, to make known,
stories that have
been deeply embedded
and a rich part of this
culture but not having space,
for me, that is a huge honor.
And I take that with incredible
sense of responsibility
with a bunch of other people.
And I think for me,
that is incredibly
inspiring and hopeful.
And there's so many more
stories that need to be told.
And we're telling those
stories to understand others,
then to understand
ourselves and understand,
how do we create a more
just and beautiful world?
So for me, I've chosen
my service as art.
Others choose other things.
And what a joyful place
to be, to actually
be inspired and re-inspired.
But what the artists are
showing us, revealing to us,
and telling us,
and the direction
that they're taking us in.
And so to be a part of
that support network
that allows art to
do that is a joy.
And it overshadows,
on most days,
all the other drudgery that
we have to deal with just
to come to our places.
So doing this work in
spite of the challenges
is what keeps me going.
And I hope what gives
us all hope for what
can be if we choose to
respect, love, and embrace
each other across
difference but connecting
to our common humanity.
So I'm excited about the work.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
It's a wonderful answer.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
Yeah, thank you.
Keith?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
Again, I feel like I just
could say, yeah, that.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
What he said.
DAVID HOWSE: You're
the truth teller.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Yeah.
Yeah.
And for me, the truth is this
odd thing that you're always--
it's like the nature of spirit.
It's this thing
that's always there.
And there's layers and
layers and layers to it.
You never can quite
define what it is.
But there it is.
And you're always looking at it.
And you're seeing it in
all that you walk through.
You walk through
life, and you see it
in everything and
everybody and everything.
And artists cannot not look.
They cannot not
contemplate what that is.
And being an artist,
the making of art
seems beyond that inspection
of all that life is.
It seems to be this sort
of purposeless compulsion
until it's not.
Until you're up there embodying
a role and saying, ah.
That was the purpose.
Ah.
This moment.
All the stuff around it is hard
and ugly and not fun to me.
And many, many ways
I could tell you
how I don't feel like this
life has been particularly fun,
because it has been this life.
But the character
in American Moor
talks about feeling the
holy pleasure of God
in doing what he does.
And I don't have a
better description of it.
When it's working,
when I'm engaged
in a theatrical experience,
and all the pieces--
everybody's behaving.
Everybody's doing
the work together.
Everybody's collaborating.
And it is messy, and it is hard.
And we're all there sacrificing
and suffering and holding it
up to the world together.
I can do no other.
If there's joy in it,
that's where it is.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
There is something so beautiful
about a group of people
who come together to tell a
really compelling story when
it's going well.
And if it's rooted in
justice and getting us
all free, all the better.
DAVID HOWSE: Yeah, that's right.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Great.
Shall we open it up?
DAVID HOWSE: Sure.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
Shall we open it up?
What's the practice here?
Do I just call on folks?
Oh, there's mics.
So folks should
line up at the mics?
Lovely.
So there's a mic
in either aisle.
Yeah.
Great.
Sorry.
I should have let you
all know that before.
I didn't know.
That's how I should
have said get ready.
Get ready and line
up at the mics.
Now we know.
Great.
So let's start on this side.
And we'll go back and forth.
Join the resistance.
I think that's you.
I was reading the t-shirt.
Yeah.
Let's start with you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I can start first.
When I was in junior high--
I was brought up in New York.
New York City.
And when I was in junior
high, one of our teachers
said, well, we're going to
take you to the theater.
I said, OK.
And the very first thing
I ever saw on the stage
was the Alvin Ailey
American Dance Theater.
My eyeballs popped
right out of my head.
I don't think one word was said
during that entire performance.
And yet, the absolute--
I mean, virtually everything
you could possibly
imagine-- all of your emotions
came through from these people.
And as time went by and I
got more and more and more
into the theater--
I am not an actor--
I started to understand
more of what it was like.
And I can understand
where you're coming from.
Bringing these things
together and moving people
towards a better
way, instead of--
when I was a kid, we had
all the stereotype things
and all that other junk.
And it didn't just
go for black people.
It went for everybody.
And it was idiotic
now that I look at it.
The intellectualism
wasn't there.
And not to say
the comedy is bad,
but you can have
intelligent comedy, too.
But I can understand and
can really connect with you
when you're saying that
you're trying and succeeding
in connecting with other people.
And that is probably
the most important thing
we can do to move towards a
better and more peaceful world.
And I thank you for that.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Thank you.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Do
you want to respond?
No?
Thank you.
Great.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I really appreciate what you're
saying about your generation
and how you're
approaching changing
things, both issues of race
and intellect and the arts.
As an aging white guy who just
happens to be a visual artist,
I can get up in
the morning and I
can look outside and be
very happy with what I see
and then go into
the studio and play.
As it relates to theater and
teaching young people today,
how do you feel about
where they're coming from?
Are they angry enough--
and I use that more or less
in quotes--
about the general situation
today to lash out?
To get out there and
really make some noise.
Will they help to
save, essentially,
what we haven't been able
to save with the horror
show that's going on today?
Thank you.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: I tell
young actors and theater makers
that they can.
I don't know if they
are angry enough,
or if the opiates of the current
age are overwhelming them.
I wonder about that, if
there are just too many ways
to distract.
But we do see younger
and younger activism,
which I am excited about.
But I tell theater makers,
and this may be cynical of me,
but I say, we've screwed it up.
It's not going to get
a whole lot better,
the theater we make.
So learn your skills
well, because it's on you.
It's on you to make theater
that saves the planet.
There's too much to
un-entrench in the way
that we make our theater and why
we make it and all that stuff
that we were just discussing.
But if they are young
and energized and have
issues and an
intention that they
want to get at the heart at--
the interesting thing about
American Moor, when I first
started doing it for
college audiences
and performing arts
programs, many of them
had been programs where
a handful of actors
are chosen for each
of the three or four
plays that they do each year.
And they dress them up,
and they move them around,
and they do Oklahoma
or whatever.
And they engage them in
theatrical competitions
around the country.
Maybe they go somewhere and win
some awards or some scholarship
money.
But they had never
seen a guy standing
on a bare stage doing
90 minutes of a play.
Nothing's there but
a guy and a story.
And they were struck by that.
And I said, yeah.
That's all you need.
That's all you need,
is the intention
and the support and the
thing that you need to say.
And people will hear
you and feel you
and the vibration will
reverberate among any audience
you put together.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID HOWSE: And
I would just add
that I do think there is
enough urgency and frustration
and anger that we will see.
And we have seen
movements and the youth
really taking the
world by storm.
But I'm not ready to give
up on the older generation.
We can't actually just wait for
the younger people to do it.
We have to start with ourselves.
And so it's not too
late to figure out
what your role is in it.
Because as silent as you are,
you're actually perpetuating.
Not that that's
what you're doing,
but I wouldn't just wait
for the younger ones
to change it for us.
We have to figure out what
role we've played in it
and how we begin to undo
that and acknowledge
that role in order for
us to move forward.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
And it was just Friday
that all the students walked
out for climate change, right?
DAVID HOWSE: That's right.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi.
I'd love to have a
beer with you guys.
But I just want to point
out a couple of thoughts,
that part of the
tragedy of the situation
is that I would bet my bottom
dollar that everybody here
gets it.
The people who wouldn't come
here on a bet don't get it
and probably never will.
I think what we have to do
with this white privilege
bullshit is that we have
to light a candle every day
in our insignificant lives,
then curse the effin darkness.
And I think we all have
a debt and an obligation
to humanity to
really push forward
and make sure that
anybody in our universe
knows where we're coming from.
And if they can't carry
that, get rid of them.
You want to comment on that?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Yes.
DAVID HOWSE: Pick me!
Pick me!
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Yes.
If your theater is good enough--
and that's a broad term--
if your theater is
striking enough,
if it invades the body
on a visceral level,
it does still change
hearts and minds.
Not everyone, because
what we're up against,
in certainly this culture and
probably the world, is fear.
This human animal is fearful.
The flesh is fearful.
The self-preservation, the need.
And when you get that
big brain and the ego,
that becomes this whole mess.
And there are people
who've sat in my play who,
just as I was saying before,
it is inconvenient for them
to take the message.
But they came, and they watched.
And others who will
say, you know, I've
been looking at this all wrong.
And I'm going to have to go
back and think about this again.
And I'm sure that's not
easy for somebody to say.
And many people have said
it over the 6 1/2 years that
we've been doing that.
So I think there's
hope more universally,
I just think we have to
make a better product.
And critics that speak back
to bad theater and say it's
bad for these reasons.
And we need to have that debate.
AUDIENCE: I wish real life
was like a Hollywood movie,
but it ain't.
KEITH HAMILTON
COBB: No, it ain't.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: David,
do you want to add to that?
DAVID HOWSE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We fight the
fight every damn day.
Thank you.
DAVID HOWSE: I'll
just say one thing.
One, you started by saying
everyone in the room gets it.
And I would say we're all--
I don't know most of you.
But we're on a journey.
Part of our challenge
is, we think we get it.
And we actually don't
actually spend the time
to really understand
what we don't get.
And sometimes in liberal
Boston, our liberal-mindedness
can be in direct conflict with
our racist actions and values.
And that's not implicating
anyone here, because we get it.
But I think that's the truth
of how the brain works.
When we've positioned ourselves
as the woke ones, the ones who
get it, we are also missing
out on our own learning.
So the fact that we are here, it
means we're just on a journey.
And the second thing
I'll say, that each one
of us in this room has
someone who is not here
and wouldn't want to be a
part of the conversation.
It is our responsibility as
individuals who care and get it
to help those who don't get it.
So we actually--
each one, teach one.
Somebody said that.
I don't remember who.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Somebody.
DAVID HOWSE: But
we actually have
to go out and bring those
who don't want to know.
But we also have to be curious
about their experiences
as well.
This is not about
just, we are right.
You're wrong.
But let's talk about
what we see differently.
And I know it sounds
Pollyanna-ish.
But I think that's
where we have to be
able to have really
honest discourse in places
that allow us to do that.
And we believe that
arts is a place that
allows us to have that honest
discourse across difference.
And put this notion
that we all get it,
because I don't know
that we actually do.
And I think that prevents us
from really moving forward.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Or
if it's even get-able.
DAVID HOWSE: Yes, exactly.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS:
The idea that it's
a journey that has an end point,
that it's a constant journey.
AUDIENCE: I'm very enticed
by the play American Moor.
And I'm so happy that you
have taken on this role.
But the blackness of the
Moor is only one dimension
of the personality.
The other one that no one
seems to be talking about
is, a Moor is also a reference
to a Moroccan and likely
an Arab Moroccan who probably
has a Muslim name as well.
What Shakespeare calls Othello
probably in today's world
would be Abdullah.
So what about the unseen
part of the Arab nature
and the Muslim connotation
to the character?
And how about my rage as
an American Muslim living
in this country who
is told that this
is a Judeo-Christian country?
Where my religion, poised to
be the world's largest maybe
in another two decades, goes
unseen and unacknowledged.
So when you talk about the
Moor, yes, the blackness
is a very important component.
But you also have to accept
that the Moorishness means
Arab and Islamic affiliation.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB:
Of course, you do.
And how about your rage?
I am with you.
And I have not yet
had the opportunity
to direct the
production of Othello
where those issues that you just
so eloquently put on the table
can be explored in
that supported forum,
where we are looking at
this person as an Arab.
Arab by way of Iberia,
perhaps, and ultimately
finds himself in Venice.
He probably speaks his Arab
language of origin, Spanish.
He's speaking Venetian
with the Venetian senate.
So this is a man of many
skills and many talents
and great intellect who they
are calling Othello because that
has somehow become his name.
And how does that affect
him as a human being?
He has to hear it
again and again.
He knows that's not his name.
But that's what his
name has become.
And this is exactly--
what you're putting on
the table is exactly
the sort of exploration
that would allow an audience
to consider some things that,
in the 25 productions of Othello
that they have seen
here in America,
they have never had to consider.
Because nobody has had
that expansive scope of
thought to put
that on the stage.
But it absolutely
needs to be there.
And guaranteed, the
audience leaving would say,
I've got to go home
and think about this.
The next time I see
a man like that,
I'm going to feel
something different.
I'm going to think
I'm going to engage
in a different way.
DAVID HOWSE: I just
have to say, I love it.
This is exactly what we need.
This is exactly what we mean.
Understanding
different perspectives.
Your energy-- first
of all, the stage
is a great place
to explore this.
But I think this is
exactly what we mean.
You're seeing it from
a different perspective
that many people would not
even have had a lens into.
And the fact that we're actually
able to have a conversation
and agree and disagree
with each other
reveals the common humanity.
And so I love that you
shared it so passionately,
your perspective.
It's exactly what
we need to happen.
It's the prompt.
This play was a prompt for this
conversation that many of us
would not have been privy to.
So I thank you for
sharing that perspective
and say that we need more
of that in this country.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'd like to know, when
you direct, produce,
or write, and work
collaboratively
with others, directors,
producers, when you're
trying to send a certain message
to the audience, that message
that you're sending
out to the audience
to hopefully make a change in
society, is that same message--
is that effective behind the
scenes with your co-workers,
your directors, producers?
DAVID HOWSE: You're going
to get somebody in trouble.
AUDIENCE: Because it appears
that, from my perspective,
that it doesn't seem
to be as effective.
But since you're working in
those roles behind the scenes,
I wanted to hear from you.
Has the message that you put
your whole heart and soul in
and try to get that message
out to society actually working
behind the scenes
with all those people?
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: May I?
DAVID HOWSE: Please.
KEITH HAMILTON COBB: Well,
what David said a minute ago
I think is very cogent to this.
And that is, everybody
kind of thinks they get it.
But we really don't
know what we don't know.
And nobody can be blamed for
being part of a culture where
these issues of race
bias, a lack of empathy
across perspectives
of privilege,
is so insidious and so big
and intertwined in everything
that we go about thinking we're
woke in many ways, when we're
not.
And the American theater
likes to pride itself
on its liberalism
and its ability
to champion gay rights and
women's rights and all that.
But it exists in a culture where
paradigms and ideology that
is as old as the slave trade
still prevails in many ways.
So it's very important for
us, if we're theater makers
and we're all involved
in the same project,
to figure out ways to call
each other on our bullshit.
And we have the ability to do
that if we're all coming there
for the same reason.
That's part of the
rehearsal work, too.
Getting in the room
and saying, hey,
let's spend a couple of days
figuring out why we're all here
and make it clear that it's
all good and it's all love.
Let's go find the
truth together.
But all of it.
All of the evolution and
spiritual up-leveling
of the culture is work and
takes constant introspection.
You've got to do it.
I've got to do it.
And I guess we'll get there.
DAVID HOWSE: Yeah.
The American theater is
an institution in America.
So it lives in a racist bubble.
And it is not exempt
from those issues.
I will say that when I--
ArtsEmerson, for
example, we want
to curate these conversations.
It was very clear to
us that, until we've
done our own work
internally, until we've
been on our own
journey, we really
are irresponsible to try
and make space for that.
And so we started
3 and 1/2 years ago
with unconscious bias,
an easy way for people
to enter into a conversation.
Three years later, we were
doing undoing racism training.
And the staff has been on a
journey of discovery for self
and also for the team.
And it has transformed the way
that we engage with each other,
and that we engage in
our own personal lives.
And so it's again, not
everyone's business
to do that work.
But for us, we thought, if we're
going to actually try and tell
these stories, we
have to make sure
that we understand
our role in it.
And so my hope is that more
organizations are actually
looking inward.
Because there's something
called virtue signaling.
We put something on
stage, and we want you
to believe this is who we are.
But when you peel
back those layers
and you see leadership
structures where they're all
white, when you see decision
makers at the table who are all
white, when we invite
a playwright of color
and surround them with
an all-white team,
what service are we doing to
that artist, to the theater,
to our audience,
and to the field?
So I think we have
a lot of work to do.
And again, I'm hopeful.
There's progress.
But when you think about pulling
back the curtain, we might be--
or maybe we wouldn't
be surprised
at what you see when you
pull back those layers.
So there's still work to be
done in the American theater,
much like there's
work to be done
in all American institutions.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Well, thank you, because I was
hoping that the next time, when
you go into an all-white
room with all white furniture
and with all white people,
that no one will ask you
or tell you and say, this is
a meeting just for directors.
DAVID HOWSE: I'm looking
forward to that day, too.
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: OK.
I think this is going have
to be our last question.
I'm getting the eye.
AUDIENCE: Well, I just saw
recently Mr. Joy on tour.
And it was terrific.
I really loved it.
And I would like you to
talk a little bit about it.
Also, people in the
audience, at least in my--
so I went to another one--
I went to Mattapan.
And some people in the
audience have seen you
for the fifth time.
So it was really terrific.
And also I think one of the
issues with theater in general,
it's expensive.
Not all the people
have recourses.
They don't have the money
to go to the theater.
And ideally, how are you
going to bring that theater
from outside the theater?
In the streets.
We need theater in the streets.
So do you have any other
projects after Mr. Joy?
Which was absolutely great.
DAVID HOWSE: Sure.
I'd be happy to
talk about Mr. Joy.
Mr. Joy is a project that
we've been working on
for several years.
It started in our
downtown venues.
It's a one-person,
one-woman show
who embodies eight
or nine characters.
Our artistic director
is here somewhere.
He could probably talk more
about this than I could.
But embodies eight
different characters
and engages issues
related to gentrification,
to sexism, to
racism, to classism.
You name it.
And it's a play that
actually speaks to you
and speaks to
everyone in the room.
You can actually see yourself.
But again, it's a prompt to many
conversations that can come.
We started downtown.
And people saw
the play and said,
we need to see
this my community.
My community needs to
have this experience.
So then we created
the first year
a tour where we were going
to the various neighborhoods.
Mattapan, Dorchester, Brighton.
Someone in the METCO program
saw the show and said,
we need this in
the METCO system.
And so then, we have now
a partnership with METCO
where we're actually taking
it out to the METCO districts.
Cohasset.
We've been to Whalen.
We've been to
Newton and Scituate.
Thank you.
And other places, because it's
a show that actually opens up
many different
conversations and creates
an opportunity for
people to understand
how they relate to
these very issues
that we're talking about.
So I'm glad that
you saw Mr. Joy.
We try to do it every year.
It just closed.
It had its last show
this weekend up in Salem.
And so we'll be doing it again.
And if you haven't
seen it, it's a show
that you will not want to miss.
So thank you.
There's the economic
aspect of the theater.
And I know many theaters
have different efforts
to make sure that it is
affordable for as many people
as possible.
I just read, I think,
in The Globe today
that the Huntington,
for example,
is making their tickets to
Romeo and Juliet for anyone 25
and under, it's completely
free for the rest
of the run the show.
I know.
That's great.
At ArtsEmerson, there's
always a ticket for $25.
So no matter where
you want to come in,
there's always a ticket at $25.
And there's a secret.
We have this thing
called $10 at 10.
So I shouldn't be
telling this broadly.
But at 10:00 on most
days, if you call in,
there are tickets for $10.
So we want to make
sure that this is
affordable for-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: Most days?
DAVID HOWSE: Most days, yes.
We want to make sure this
is affordable for everybody.
But there is an
economic aspect to it,
because as you make space for
more people in the theater,
those people who have
been long-term patrons
feel like it means
it's no space for them.
So it's like a zero sum game.
If you let those people in with
the cheap tickets, then what
about my experience?
And so we have to create
audiences that welcome
and embrace people from
all over the areas.
But I know that the
financial barrier for entry
can be problematic for people.
And we have to figure out a
way to find funding mechanisms.
Look at the funding structures,
look at the support structure,
so that we can make sure that
this is the people's work.
Not some people's work.
But everybody's work.
And that takes all of
us lobbying, advocating,
supporting, making
noise to say, we need
to make these
institutions and the work
that these institutions are
creating in partnerships
with community-based
organizations,
make sure that it's
available for everybody
LIZZY COOPER DAVIS: Great.
Thank you all so
much for showing up.
I want to say one last
thing about showing up.
It's part of our
responsibility to this work.
So showing up for
the conversation,
yes, this is a conversation
that lots of folks
are having in this city.
I want to name just a few and
say, show up for them as well.
Front Porch Arts is a really
important new black theater
company--
I think I see some
folks in the house--
committed to advancing
racial equity in Boston
through theater.
There's a really
interesting conversation
about Asian-American
experience happening
in Boston right now with
Vietgone, coming soon
from Company One, which is
another company very much
committed to this conversation.
Endlings, which just
left at the A.R.T.
The Dragon Cycle,
coming to Oberon.
The Theater Offensive is
an extraordinary leader
locally and nationally
around queer, transgender,
nonconforming stories, often
featuring and focused on PoC.
Local director Megan
Sandberg-Zakian
is one of the founders
of Maia Directors,
a national collective of
four theater makers of Middle
Eastern-North African
descent working
to bring more of those stories
to the stage and screen.
And when Keith
Hamilton Cobb shows up
with American Moor to
a theater near you,
show up for that as well.
Thank you for coming.